speaking of a bad set of ideas one of
the one of the Liberals that you know
I'm always working on is disaffected
liberal but still self-proclaimed
liberal uh Bill Maher Bill Maher is
struggling with his own team because
they not no longer believe in diversity
of thought and Bill Maher recently was
talking about where that rot comes from
and I think he nailed it I really think
look we we are I think when historians
look back at our time they will not
divide us into red and blue and
Republican Democrat they're like the
things that were wrong with us were
wrong with both sides in different ways
I do think they manifest in a more
dangerous way on the right but on the
left there is a rot and it comes from
Academia and I agree and it filters down
am I am I wrong about that that's where
it's all coming from I just think this
is an epitome of it this is what the
mother says and then the kid robbed your
money
it's quite true the place in American
society really all Western Society where
the the horrific ideas of leftism and
wokism and collectivism socialism these
top-down ideas these ideas that are
anti-human Liberty they're anti the
individual because they don't want you
thinking for yourself they want to think
for you these have all taken root at
universities uh throughout this country
and as I said throughout the world so he
is getting it on that point they will
scream till their heads explode about
diversity but of course as you guys know
the one diversity that they hate is
diversity of thought and this is
something that I think a whole bunch of
people did not we we just thought the
thing was going to work we just thought
oh you could send your kid to a school
to get a degree in lesbian badminton and
whatever it might be and you'll spend a
lot of money doing it but the machine
will just keep working and they'll just
get a job and everything will be okay
but now now after probably four Decades
of this indoctrination we are seeing the
fruits of that and you have to give
credit to the Socialist you have to give
credit to all of these people who said
we will start at the schools and we will
indoctrinate Youth and does that sound a
little something similar to what's going
on with all these uh trans drag shows or
or drag queen drag shows kid drag shows
whatever the hell's going on over there
like you get them young you confuse them
with bad ideas young you show a
six-year-old a dude in a dress dancing
around saying crazy things and it's not
it's just to confuse them because a
confused mind is is fertile ground to a
to a solid a stolen rest of your life
something like that
foreign
[Music]